can ask a dark
question as opposed to the other things
we've been talking about
well there's there's always a thread a
hopeful message i think it'll be a
hopeful message on this one too you may
have the wrong guest
um if you were to bet money
on the way that human civilization
destroys itself
or it collapses in some way that
is where the result would be
unrecognizable to us
as anything akin to progress
what would you say is it nuclear weapons
is it some societal breakdown through
just more traditional kinds of war
is it engineered pandemics
nanotechnology is it artificial
intelligence
is it something we can't even expect yet
do you have a sense of how we humans
will destroy ourselves
or might we live forever i think what
what governs my view of this thing is
is the ability for us to focus ourselves
collectively right and that gives me the
choice
of looking at this and saying what are
the odds we will do
x versus y right um so go look at the 62
cuban missile crisis where we
looked at the potential of nuclear war
and we stared right in the face of that
to me i consider that to be you want to
talk about a hopeful moment
that's one of the rare times in our
history where i think the odds
were overwhelmingly that there would be
a nuclear war
and uh i'm not the super kennedy
worshiper that you know i grew up in an
era where he was
especially amongst uh people in the
democratic party he was almost worshiped
and i was never that guy but i will say
something
john f kennedy by himself um
probably made decisions that saved a
hundred million or more lives
because everyone around him thought he
should be
taking the road that would have led to
those deaths and to push back against
that
is when you look at it now i mean again
if you were a betting person you would
have bet against that
and that's rare right um so
so when we talk about how the world will
end
um the fact that one person actually had
that
in their hands meant that it wasn't a
collective decision
it gave remember i said i trust people
on an individual level but when we get
together we're more like a herd and we
devolve down to the lowest common
denominator
that was something where the higher uh
ethical
ideas of a single human being could come
into play and make the decisions that
that influence the events but when we
have to act
collectively i get a lot more
pessimistic so take
what we're doing to the planet and we
talk about it always now in terms of
climate change
which i think is far too narrow uh look
at
you know and and i i always get very
frustrated when we talk about these
arguments about is it happening is it
human
just look at the trash forget forget
climb it for a second
we are destroying the planet because
we're not taking care of it and because
what it would do to take care of it
would require collective sacrifices
that would require enough of us to say
okay
and and we can't get enough of us to say
because too many people have to be on
board it's not john f kennedy making one
decision from one man
we have to have 85 percent of us or
something around the world
not just you can't say we're going to
stop uh uh doing damage to the to the
to the world here in the united states
if china does it right so the amount of
people that have to get on board that
train
is hard you get pessimistic hoping for
those
kinds of shifts unless it's right
you know krypton's about to explode we
have and so
i think if you're talking about a
gambling man's view of this
that that's got to be the odds on
favorite because it requires such a
unanimous i mean and the systems maybe
aren't even in place right
the fact that we would need
intergovernmental bodies that are
completely discredited now on board and
you would have to subvert uh the
national interests of nation-states i
mean the
the amount of things that have to go
right
in a short period of time we don't have
600 years to figure this out
right so to me that that looks like the
most likely just because the things we
would have to do to avoid it seem the
most unlikely does that make sense yes
absolutely
i i believe call me naive in
just like you said with the individual i
believe that charismatic leaders
individual leaders will save us like
this what if you don't get them all at
the same time
what if you get a charismatic leader in
one country but under or what if you get
a charismatic leader in a country that
doesn't really matter that much
well it's a ripple effect so it starts
with one leader and
their charisma inspires other leaders
like so
it's a it's like one ant queen steps up
and then the rest of the ant starts
behaving
and then there's like little other
spikes of leaders that emerge
and then that's where collaboration
emerges i tend to believe that like
when you heat up the system and
starts getting
really chaotic then
the leader whatever this collective
intelligence that we've developed
the leader will emerge like do you think
there's just as much of a chance though
that the leader would emerge and say the
jews are the people who did all this
right
you know what i'm saying is that the
idea that they would come up you have a
charismatic leader and he's going to
come up with the rights or she
is going to come up with the right
solution as opposed to totally
coming up with the wrong solution i mean
i guess what i'm saying is
you could be right but a lot of things
have to go the right way
but my intuition about the evolutionary
process that led to the creation of
human
intelligence and consciousness on earth
results in the the power of
like if we think of it just the love in
the system versus the hate in the system
that the love is greater the human
the the the the human kindness
potential in the system is greater than
the human
uh hatred potential and so the leader
that is
in the time when it's needed the leader
that
inspires love and kindness will
is more likely to emerge and will have
more power
so you have the hitlers of the world
that emerge
but they're actually in a grand scheme
of history
are not that impactful so
it's it's weird to say but not that many
people died in world war ii
if you look at the the the the full
range of human history uh you know it's
uh you've got up to 100 million
whatever that is with natural pandemics
too you can have those kinds of numbers
but it's still
a percentage i forget what the
percentage is maybe three five percent
of the human population on earth maybe
it's a little bit focused on a different
region
but it's not destructive to the entirety
of human civilization
so the i believe that the
the charismatic leaders when time is
needed
that do good for the world in
uh the broader sense of good are more
likely to emerge than the ones that say
kill all the jews i it's it's possible
though
and this is just you know i've thought
about this all of 30 seconds but i mean
uh
it it's we're betting money here on the
on the 21st century who's gonna win
i think maybe uh you've divided this
into too much of a black and white
dichotomy
this love and good on one side and this
evil on another let me throw
something that might be more in the
center of that linear
a balancing act self-interest
which may or may not be good you know
good the good version of it we call
enlightened self-interest right
the bad version of it we call
selfishness
but self-interest to me seems like
something more likely to
impact the outcome than either love on
one side or evil on the other
simply a question of what's good for me
or what's good for my country
or what's good from my point of view or
what's good for my business
i mean if you tell me um and
maybe i i'm a coal miner or maybe i own
a coal mine
if you say to me we have to stop using
coal because it's hurting the earth
i have a hard time disentangling
that greater good question from my
right now good feeding my family
question right
so i think i think maybe it's going to
be a much more banal
thing than good and evil much more a
question of
we're not all going to decide at the
same time
that the interests that we have are
aligned
does that make sense totally but i mean
i've looked at ayn rand and objectivism
and kind of really thought like how bad
or good can things go when everybody's
acting selfishly
but i think we're just talking two ants
here with microphones
talking about two seconds with microsoft
but like the the question is
when they when this spreads so what what
is what do i mean by love and kindness
i think it's human flourishing on earth
and throughout the cosmos
it feels like whatever the engine that
drives human beings
is more likely to result in human
flourishing
and people like hitler are not good for
human flourishing
so that's what i mean by good is they is
is there's a i mean maybe it's an
intuition that
kindness is an evolutionary advantage
i hate those terms i hate to reduce
stuff to the evolutionary biology always
but
it just seems like for us to multiply
throughout the universe
it's good to be kind to each other
and those leaders will always emerge to
save us
from the hitlers of the world that want
to kind of burn the thing down with the
flamethrower
that's the intuition but let's talk
about you you brought up evolution
several times
let me let me play with that for a
minute um
i think going back to animal times we
are conditioned
to deal with overwhelming threats right
in front of us so i have quite a bit of
faith
in humanity when it comes to impending
doom
right outside our door uh if krypton's
about to explode i think humanity can r
rouse themselves to great and would give
power to the people who needed it and be
willing to make the sacrifices
but that's what makes i think the the
pollution slash climate change slash
you know screwing up your environment um
uh threats so particularly insidious
is it happens slowly right it defies
fight and flight mechanisms it defies
the natural ability we have to deal with
the threat that's
right on top of us and it requires an
amount of foresight that while some
people would would be fine with that
most people are too worried and
understandably i think too worried
about today's threat rather than next
generations threat or whatever it might
be
so i mean when we talk about when you
had said what what do you think the
greatest threat is
i think with nuclear weapons i think
could we have a nuclear war we darn
right could but i i think that there's
enough
of of inertia we're against that because
people
understand instinctively if i decide to
launch this attack against
china and i'm india we're going to have
50 million dead people tomorrow
whereas if you say we're going to have a
whole planet of dead people in three
generations if we don't start now
i think the evolutionary uh
way that we have have evolved mitigates
maybe against that in other words i
think i would be pleasantly surprised if
we could pull that off does that make
sense
totally i don't mean to be like that i'm
the i'm the scripting doom
it's fun that way i think we're both uh
maybe i'm over the top on the left
maybe i'm over the top on the doom so it
makes
it makes for a fun chat i think
you